la bandera de colombia de filo esta
noche por la alfombra roja del festival
de cannes y es que finalmente pudimos
ver en competencia oficial memoria la
película del tailandés apichatpong
weerasethakul una película de un
director asiático pero que sin embargo
fue producida y filmada completamente en
colombia está protagonizada por la
británica tilda swinton que representa
una mujer que viene a visitar a su
hermana al país sudamericano y empieza a
escuchar unos ruidos extraños durante la
alfombra roja entonces los actores
colombianos de la película elkin díaz y
juan pablo orrego sacaron la bandera de
colombia con la sigla eso es en
referencia a la manifestaciones que han
tenido lugar en este país sudamericano
en los últimos meses sino también se
presentó en competición la francesa
france que hace una crítica de la
sociedad francesa a través de una
periodista de televisión y la marroquí
alto y fuerte que cuenta la historia de
un antiguo rapero que intenta liberar a
la juventud de las tradiciones a través
del hip hop sino también empezaron a
entregarse premios aquí en el festival
de cannes concretamente de la
cinefundación que apoya a las escuelas
de cine del mundo el tercer lugar fue
la academia internacional de cine de
brasil